The "Jackass" crew have been called "the elder
statesmen of self-inflicted harm" — but time
catches up with all of us. So now that Johnny
Knoxville and company have reached middle age,
is a fifth "Jackass" movie even
physically possible for them?
Back in the '90s, Johnny Knoxville wasn't yet the
star we know today. Much like one of his
influences, writer Hunter S. Thompson,
Knoxville was up for anything and everything,
including testing self-defense equipment on
himself for "Big Brother" magazine.
His risk-taking didn't go unnoticed,
and before long the magazine was gaining
attention from other like-minded daredevils,
including Steve-O. Soon enough, the likes of Chris
Pontius and Jason "Wee Man" Acuña came on board,
bolstered by behind-the-scenes staff such as
Jeff Tremaine and Spike Jonze. This ragtag team
made quirky videos for the early internet, and it
didn't take too long before people took notice.
With the prospect of branching out into
a television show, a few more talents
were added to the ranks, including skater Bam
Margera and his buddy, Ryan Dunn. This proved
to be the final ingredient and, following some
network shopping, the crew signed up with MTV.
"Jackass" made its television debut in April
2000 and was a near-overnight success. In no
time at all, Knoxville went from doing random
commercials to make ends meet, to posing for
the cover of Rolling Stone. The show's success
saw them break out onto the big screen in 2002,
with "Jackass: The Movie." Three more movies would
follow, including 2022's "Jackass Forever."
Following the box office success of 2010's
"Jackass 3D," the franchise was fairly
dormant for most of the 2010s. The idea of
a fourth film never quite went away though,
with many fans still craving more. Sadly, in 2011,
cast member Ryan Dunn was killed in a car crash at
the age of 34. This was a tremendous loss for
the crew, and his death was especially hard on
Bam Margera, who had already been struggling with
substance abuse issues prior to Dunn's passing.
"This is not right. It's not right."
Margera's substance issues returned during the
production of "Jackass Forever," as Paramount
Pictures was hesitant to allow him to appear in
the film. These fears were later substantiated
when they became a source of conflict
between Margera and the film's producers,
including Jeff Tremaine, Spike Jonze, and Johnny
Knoxville. Margera even went as far as to publicly
rant about his treatment on Instagram, alleging
he was being treated like an animal by the studio.
He also threatened his former friends, resulting
in Tremaine slapping Margera with a restraining
order. This resulted in Margera being fired
from "Jackass Forever" and, aside from one stunt
and a handful of background appearances,
he was removed from the film entirely.
Aside from the very public break-up with Bam
Margera, another issue the "Jackass Forever"
crew had to overcome was the COVID-19 pandemic,
which had put Hollywood on an indefinite pause.
While most productions simply pumped the
brakes until they were allowed to resume,
the "Jackass" crew were given some leeway
by Paramount. The studio used the film as
an excuse to see what future productions
could achieve during the pandemic. This
was confirmed by Wee Man during an interview
on "The Nine Club With Chris Roberts," where
he also explained other ways the pandemic
affected production. It seems that the team
wanted to film stuff on location in some exotic
locales. However, due to travel restrictions
and the varying nature of COVID-19 testing in
different countries, this had to be scrapped.
With the arrival of various vaccines, things
regarding COVID-19 have become much more
manageable than they were at the pandemic's peak.
So with that hurdle removed, it'll likely be much
easier to film a potential fifth theatrical
film, should they decide to pursue it.
"Jackass Forever" really did feel like
a changing of the guard for the series,
especially when it came to the cast. While most
of the original cast was back for another round,
this entry also introduced some new blood —
predominantly because many of the original crew
couldn't push themselves as hard as they used to.
The new cast featured Sean "Poopies" McInerney,
Zach Holmes, Jasper Dolphin, Eric Manaka, and
Rachel Wolfson. This means that "Jackass Forever"
saw not only its first Black cast members
but its first female cast member as well.
Change is never easy for any long-running
franchise but in this instance, the new additions
didn't feel forced or reductive in any way. None
of them felt out of place and it even allowed for
some fresh reactions to things that perhaps the
old cast might've been desensitized to. "Jackass"
has always been a series built off of youthful
vigor, so this development makes absolute sense,
and could see the franchise continuing even
when the OGs are no longer part of the crew.
When it comes to the cast of "Jackass," you'd be
hard-pressed to find a member more dedicated than
Steve-O. From swimming with sharks to bungee
jumping in an excrement-loaded porta potty,
Steve-O is the "Jackass" crew's indispensable man.
However, that doesn't mean it's always been
peaches and cream for Steve-O. Both the third
and fourth films were especially hard for the
self-proclaimed Wild Boy for different reasons.
"Jackass 3D" was Steve-O's first production
after achieving his sobriety — something the
crew all helped him with. Despite his lifestyle
transition, Steve-O was still as gung ho as ever.
When it came to "Jackass Forever" though, Steve-O
said in an interview with Entertainment Weekly
that it was "kind of a bummer." He went on
to explain that this attitude stemmed from
seeing what Johnny Knoxville was still
subjecting himself to physically at his
age. He specifically referred to a stunt that
involved Knoxville being charged into by a bull,
which resulted in severe brain
damage. Steve-O told the outlet:
"It's not fun to watch Knoxville
get hit in the head anymore."
"So what happened after it hit me?"
"Dude, it's gnarly."
As a result, it seems unlikely we'll
see Steve-O — or possibly any member of
the "Jackass" crew — in a fifth feature film.
However, we may see them join forces for some
other project. Speaking with CinemaBlend
in August 2023, the daredevil explained,
"I wouldn't be surprised if some
kind of project reunited us again,
but I wouldn't bet on there being another movie."
The "Jackass" movies have always been a bit of
an anomaly, as you wouldn't expect films of their
caliber to amass positive buzz from the press.
However, with the exception of the first film,
all of the main theatrical films have positive
Rotten Tomatoes scores. "Jackass Forever" stands
as the highest-rated entry in the entire
series and it isn't hard to see why. Nick
Schager of Esquire described the original
cast as "elder statesman of self-inflicted
harm" — which is an apt description if
we've ever heard one. Schager also wrote:
"In a pandemic era of extreme caution and fear,
it's a welcome relief to watch Knoxville and the
rest risk life and limb for the sheer hell of it."
Many critics seemed to share the same sentiment,
with Brett Doze of InSession Film saying,
"I'm not going to pretend there is some
thought-provoking, underlying message
that wasn't there before, but I certainly did
enjoy laughing my ass off with these friends."
That ultimately might just be the appeal of
these movies — the feeling of reconnecting
with something or someone from your past.
With "Jackass Forever" being both a critical
and commercial success, many have wondered
if "Jackass 5" will be happening. Sadly,
as of September 2023, very little
has been said about a fifth film,
aside from a few scant comments. The
"Jackass" films aren't like other movies,
as they don't have a screenplay or even a
three-act narrative. As opposed to a plot,
the movies are more of an eclectic compilation
of crazy stunts and pranks of varying scales.
"My god."
"Are you crying?"
"I think he's hurt."
Additionally, many of the best moments
in the films aren't even planned,
with several highlights originating as something
thought up on the spot. An example of this would
be the "Rocky" prank from "Jackass 3D," wherein
Bam Margera would surprise someone with a splash
of water and a punch to the head. You can't script
or coordinate spontaneity like that, and this is
a key factor in the films. If a fifth "Jackass"
movie was announced, we probably wouldn't see a
scrap of footage from it for a very long time.
However, when and if that day finally comes,
you can rest assured that hardcore fans of
the series will be waiting with bated breath.
Much of the "Jackass" franchise's DNA
stems from Johnny Knoxville. From its
humble origins to what it has become, the
man is undoubtedly the series' figurehead.
Though it might be a head that has been
rattled by a few sizable concussions,
it's still one that has helped
steer the ship since the beginning.
Any mentions of a potential
fifth entry have been limited,
with Knoxville himself providing
the closest thing to an update.
In an interview with Variety, Knoxville
addressed the future of the series, saying,
"We never said whether it was or wasn't [the final
film]. [...] If we did continue, we would lean on
the younger cast more and the old guys would take
a little step back but still be a part of it."
"There may be another Jackass, there may not be."
Addressing his own part in a possible
"Jackass 5," Knoxville went on to add,
"I would have to step back because my neurologist
said I can't have any more concussions."
Knoxville is the lynchpin of the show, and
even if he did have to step back from some
of the more physically demanding stunts, it still
would be great to see him play a part. After all,
"Jackass" wouldn't be the same without
Knoxville's infectious cackling.
"Right?! God help me, I love it."
Throughout the "Jackass" series and movies,
we've seen different stunts and pranks
that the crew has pulled off. With acts
of lewd depravity and rampant insanity,
they've elicited both hysterical laughter
and visceral disgust in equal measure.
We've seen Johnny Knoxville take to the
sky on a big red rocket and Steve-O perform
the grossest bungee jump anyone has seen.
Most of us would flee at the mere thought of
attempting acts like this, but the "Jackass"
crew will do it with a smile on their faces. There
have also been pranks of varying scales as well,
including a limousine packed with a swarm of bees,
as well as a comically giant hand to smack people.
Needless to say, the creative juices have always
been flowing behind the scenes on "Jackass."
With "Jackass Forever" bringing us things
such as a shock collar game involving a bear,
and pogo sticks to the nether regions, where
can they go from here? With people becoming
increasingly desensitized, the crew will
need to find creative ways to up the ante.
With the prospect of a fifth "Jackass" film not
disappearing anytime soon, we need to consider
who would be returning for another round.
While perhaps in less of a hands-on role,
Johnny Knoxville would likely return as the
maniacal leader spearheading the whole thing.
Long-serving cast members including Wee Man,
Steve-O, and Chris Pontius have also appeared in
all of the theatrical releases so far, so it is
hoped they would also sign up for more madness.
There is also the ever-loyal supporting
cast of Dave England, Preston Lacy,
and Danger Ehren — three men who've never
had issues going above the call of duty.
From being used as human football
goals to playing beehive tetherball,
they've always thrown themselves
headfirst into whatever was needed.
However, as "Jackass Forever" showed us, the
old guard seems to be passing the torch to a
new generation of untrained stunt performers.
These fresh faces each have a clear love for
the series, many of them having grown up
with it in the early '00s. It seems that
as long as there are people bold enough
to push themselves to the very limit,
then the spirit of "Jackass" will never die.
Whether for a fifth film or for another series,
it remains to be seen whether we will see
more from our favorite pranksters or not.